we were just with Oliver we were just
holding him and stroking and I was
talking to him and just wanting those
last moments with him while he was warm
you don't really believe it you do feel
like he's going to wake up and I was
trying to hold his hand and I felt like
you he would hold it back but he didn't
when you get your children to the age of
30 they've done well at school they've
got a good job you feel like your jobs
done really you don't worry so much
they're not teenagers anymore so it's
this is a mighty blow forever are you
presumably we're thinking about teaching
yep we were planning on buying a house
and I was trying to save some money to
put towards and a big property and we
were planning on having and having
children as well and it's something that
we both discussed them for something
them that unfortunately now can't happen
but for all of them walk more so than
myself but he was the one I was meant to
have done all of that sort of thing with
you know get married and have children
and you know sort of liver a great life
together really
and I imagine that you just have to
contemplate a totally different well
it's just you have to rebuild rebuild it
you know if your future release what's
what was normal was now not normal and
having to kind of restart everything
really yeah I don't know your house to
really kind of put it but I guess it was
a it was a moment a single moment that
changed everything yeah to know that it
was a single act like that just a single
sort of wind decision from one person
that is what was that way it's just it's
necessary so unnecessary and so wasteful
of a life
for no reason
do you remember the last time you spoke
to
Claire when Oliver came for tea or
dinner on Thursday previous to that
Saturday it was beautiful evening we sat
in the garden we discussed his holiday
and how he was looking forward to it
because he was going to Las Vegas with
his friends on the Tuesday for a
collective 30th celebration I cooked his
favorite food he joked with Jeff step
dad that he got the larger stake as
usual and we had he hugged me on the
doorstep and said see mama said you take
care and have a good time and that was
that um so I'm a nurse and I've had
finished a night shift on that Saturday
morning and I came home had a couple of
hours sleep and then I we've got like
got up and we spent a few hours together
before he he ventured out to seize
friends and I was the last time I saw
him I got a message from him at about
ten-thirty and evening while she was
about ten o'clock just saying they loan
no I love you and that was it that was
the last lastly
memories must be very important at this
point when you when you think of me
think of him how do you remember and
lots of good memories lots and lots of
good memories and lots of holidays spent
together and you know I missed so much
even the smallest little things you know
him coming home asking me what's for
dinner and you know moaning at me that
I've not done his washing or something
do you know just all the little things
you kind of take for granted and you
know you every day util you complain
about it's those things that you kind of
icon and a miss